Jeremy Hunt a crisis chancellor has a
plan for long-term growth education
Enterprise employment and optimism
declinism about Britain is just wrong
it's always been wrong in the past
and it's wrong today
if that sounds like a brexiteers lament
the consequences of leaving remain
contested a barrier for many in business
but not the chancellor the reality of
brexit for many companies is delays red
tape additional costs they can't hire
the people they want to come to this
country and you can't stop the people
you don't want to come to this country
would it not be more honest to
acknowledge that brexit is failing on
its own terms it's a big change in our
economic relations with our closest
neighbors and of course that is going to
need adaptation and of course there is
some short-term disruption but I think
it's completely wrong to just focus on
that without looking at the
opportunities
foreign
fellow they contend with reality A
supplier of specialist materials for
High-Tech research it's precisely the
sort of Enterprise the chancellor wants
to thrive
but with almost half their goods
exported to Europe they face challenges
what we've done is is we we've got an
operating company in Germany and and
we've had to ship through that company
so a lot of taxes that would have gone
through to the the UK now now are
declared in Germany uh and they then we
ship to all the 27 EU countries brexit
and covid have contributed to a worker
shortage to Mr Hunt wants an army of
retirees to come to the rescue Britain
is not alone in facing economic
challenges but it is the only G7 nation
that hasn't recovered to pre-pandemic
levels of output and the chancellor
faces difficult choices ruling out tax
cuts after spending billions on covid
and energy bailouts but under pressure
from business to incentivize investment
what we now want to see is the action
for example in the spring Budget on the
things that are you know essential to
our growth and that's not you know those
aren't small things that's things like
getting older people back to work or
getting mums back to work who can't work
because of child care that is about
incentivizing Investments like the super
deduction and things like that the
chancellor wants to look on the bright
side but whether Optimist or pessimist
economic reality will have the last word
Paul Kelso Sky News